[S01] 欢迎来到The Debate呃，通常当我们谈论工具的时候，人们总是有一种对瑞士军刀的浪漫幻想
[S02] 确实，就是那种你把它放在口袋里，觉得无论遇到什么突发状况，这一个小小的物理实体都能应付
[S01] 没错，一把刀包含了几十种小工具，能开罐头，能锯木头，还能拧螺丝。它小巧，自洽，似乎能解决所有问题
[S02] 在软件工程里，这也是一种极具诱惑力的极简主义，对吧？
[S01] 对，但我经常想，如果你走进一家米其林三星餐厅的后厨，你绝对看不到主厨在用瑞士军刀处理食材
[S02] 哼，哈哈，那画面确实挺滑稽的
[S01] 是吧？你在那里看到的是高度专业化的分工，专门处理海鲜的工作台，精确控温的分子料理设备，还有庞大且复杂的排气与冷链系统。诶，所以今天我们将探讨数据密集型应用架构中的核心权衡
[S02] 没错，这其实就是关于我们到底需要瑞士军刀，还是工业级后厨的根本争议
[S01] 精确地说，本次探讨基于《设计数据密集型应用》第二版第一章的内容，我们将审视现代数据系统在演进过程中面临的关键岔路口
[S02] 也就是在数据量激增的今天，我们要搞清楚一条核心界限
[S01] 是的，核心争议在于，数据系统是否必然要走向高度专业化，计算与存储分离的云原生分布式架构，还是说，呃，我们低估了现代单节点系统的强大潜力，以及出于合规与运维成本考量而进行数据最小化的必要性
[S02] 这个分歧其实非常深刻
[S01] 我代表的立场是坚决拥抱这种复杂性的。我认为系统的高度专业化，云原生分布式架构以及计算与存储的解耦，是应对现在高度可变的业务负载和海量数据的必要之路
[S02] 而我呢，代表呼吁克制与极简的立场。我认为技术界对云端和分布式系统的盲目扩张，其实往往得不偿失。现代的单节点系统完全足以应对绝大多数的实际需求
[S01] 但这就引出了一个非常关键的点，就是现代应用面临的负载不仅庞大，而且特征极其多变，单一的数据系统真的早就无法胜任复杂的全局需求了
[S02] 我觉得你这有点夸大了单一系统的瓶颈
[S01] 哎，你先听我说完。我们必须将系统在逻辑上划分为事务型，也就是 OLTP和分析型 OLAP。不仅如此，为了满足数据科学家截然不同的需求，系统还必须演进出数据湖
[S02] 就是所谓的把所有东西都先存起来
[S01] 没错，就是遵循所谓的以防万一原则，保留原始的未经加工的数据，以供未来的机器学习使用。在物理层面上，云原生架构通过解耦存储与计算，比如将亚马逊 S3 这样的对象存储与Snowflake结合，再加上无服务器架构的按需自动扩缩容，彻底解决了传统本地部署中资源闲置或单点故障的死结
[S02] 哇，听起来非常宏大，简直是一个完美的乌托邦。但我必须指出，技术界对分布式云架构的狂热追求，常常是一种性能和成本上的巨大陷阱
[S01] 陷阱，我不这么认为
[S02] 确实是陷阱。正如文献中提到的那篇著名论文，可伸缩性，但代价是什么？很多时候，一个简单的单线程程序在一台普通的单节点计算机上运行，它的性能甚至能超越拥有上百个 CPU 核心的庞大分布式集群
[S01] 但单机的上限就摆在那里啊
[S02] 可问题是为了追求你说的所谓的无限扩展，我们引入了网络调用的高延迟，引入了需要极为复杂的追踪工具才能排错的微服务架构，我们真的应该重新审视单节点的巨大价值
[S01] 即使它不能无缝横向扩展
[S02] 是的，而且你们这种先收集原始数据再说的大数据投机哲学，呃，直接违背了数据隐私法中的数据最小化原则，这个我们稍后一定要好好聊聊
[S01] 好，那我们不妨从你刚刚提到的工作负载划分来展开。工作负载的根本差异，其实决定了物理隔离的绝对必要性。你想想，事务型系统也就是 OLTP，它需要的是什么？
[S02] 极低延迟的点查询
[S01] 对，极低延迟的点查询。用户在手机上点击付款，系统必须在几毫秒内通过主键找到那条记录，扣减余额并更新。而分析型系统呢，数据科学家可能需要扫描数十亿条记录来提取特征或者训练模型
[S02] 这两者的访问模式确实不同
[S01] 何止是不同，在底层机制上，这两类操作对硬件资源的索取是完全互斥的。如果你把它们放在一起，就是灾难
[S02] 等等，我不认为它们必须被强行物理隔离。你知道，将这两种工作负载隔离，不可避免地催生了极其沉重的数据管道负担
[S01] 你是说ETL这些？
[S02] 对啊，维护数据湖需要庞大的ETL，也就是提取、转换、加载，甚至还有反向 ETL管道。一旦源数据库的表结构发生一点点改变，整个下游的分析管道就可能崩盘
[S01] 这确实是个痛点，但这是必要的代价
[S02] 但这就造成了数据在不同系统间同步时的巨大延迟和不一致啊。文献中提到了混合事务与分析处理系统的兴起，也就是 HTAP。HTAP证明了我们完全可以在单个系统中同时支持高并发事务和复杂分析，而不需要把数据搬来搬去
[S01] 嗯，HTAP在理论上确实很吸引人，但我们要看它的底层执行逻辑，将事务和分析放在同一个系统里，这就像是要求米其林大厨在同一个操作台上工作
[S02] 怎么说？
[S01] 你想象一下，一边小心翼翼地烤制一个需要精确控温的舒芙蕾，这就是我们要求毫秒级响应的事务查询，另一边呢，却同时在用电锯解剖一整头牛。这头牛就是分析型系统对海量数据的全表扫描
[S02] 这个比喻有点吓人，但很有意思
[S01] 确实是这样啊，解剖这头牛会瞬间占满整个操作台的空间，消耗掉所有的 CPU 缓存和内存带宽。这时候，烤舒芙蕾的烤箱直接断电了，事务查询被迫在队列里等待，直接导致面向用户的应用界面卡死。这种资源争抢，难道不是一种灾难吗？
[S02] 哈哈，这个舒芙蕾和牛的比喻确实很生动，但在现实中，你忽略了现代硬件的飞跃
[S01] 但它改变了容量的量级吧
[S02] 但它改变了容量的量级。现在的厨房操作台，也就是服务器的主内存，已经大到可以同时容纳舒芙蕾和那头牛了。我们现在有了TB 级别的内存，还有高度优化的列式存储格式，它们能将分析查询的内存占用压缩到极小
[S01] 但它仍然在同一个物理机器上抢占 CPU 周期
[S02] 是的，但 HTAP并非只适用于小规模场景。对于欺诈检查，这种既需要低延迟锁定，又需要大规模历史数据扫描的业务，它极其高效。更重要的是，选择 HTAP意味着你不需要雇佣一支庞大的数据工程师团队，每天疲于奔命地去维护那些脆弱的 ETL管道
[S01] 呃，好，假设我们暂时接受单系统在逻辑层面能够处理混合负载，但这立刻将我们引向了支撑这些系统的底层物理基础建设
[S02] 你是指云原生架构吧
[S01] 对，即使是单系统，如果它运行在云端，也应该遵循云原生架构的精髓，也就是存储与计算的彻底解耦。在传统机器上，CPU和本地磁盘是物理绑定的
[S02] 也就是最典型的服务器形态
[S01] 没错，但在云原生系统里，我们将大块数据放入像 S3 这样的对象存储中，这使得计算实例变得无状态，这非常重要
[S02] 你是为了弹性扩容，对吧？
[S01] 是的，当遇到突发的巨大流量时，我们可以自由地在几秒钟内拉起成百上千个计算节点来处理请求，而无需等待数据的漫长迁移。当流量退去，又可以瞬间销毁它们。这种计算能力的极致弹性，是任何把 CPU 和硬盘绑死在同一个机箱里的系统都难以企及的
[S02] 听起来确实像魔法一样完美，不过物理定律是骗不了人的嘛
[S01] 什么意思？云端的扩展性不是已经被验证过了吗？
[S02] 扩展性是一回事，但延迟是另一回事。当你将本地磁盘替换为通过网络访问的虚拟块设备或云端对象存储时，这就意味着你系统的每一次底层的 IO 操作，每一次读写都变成了一次网络调用
[S01] 但云厂商的内部网络速度非常快，他们用的是顶级的网络设备，
[S02] 速度再快，性质也完全变了呀。如果是本地 NVMe 固态硬盘，数据是通过主板上的 PCIe总线传输的，那个延迟在微秒甚至纳秒级别
[S01] 确实很快
[S02] 但一旦解耦放到云端，一个简单的读取指令需要穿透操作系统的网络栈，虚拟化层，通过数据中心的物理交换机到达另一台存储服务器，然后再原路返回。这中间的延迟往往是毫秒级的
[S01] 毫秒级对于大多数应用也是可以接受的
[S02] 但你硬生生把 IO 速度拖慢了上千倍啊，而且网络会抖动，交换机会拥塞，你将系统完全暴露在了网络分区的巨大风险之下。文献中清楚地指出，在处理海量数据时，将计算移动到数据所在的位置，通常比通过网络移动海量数据要快得多
[S01] 我明白你想表达的关于网络开销的担忧。但是你看，在全球化应用的语境下，如果不使用分布式云存储，单节点系统难道不是一个巨大的单点故障风险吗？
[S02] 单点故障当然可以通过复制来解决
[S01] 但对于一个需要服务全球用户的应用来说，单机根本无法满足容错需求。如果那台拥有极速 NVMe 硬盘的服务器主板烧了，或者它所在的机房断电了，整个业务就彻底停摆了，不是吗？
[S02] 那是极端情况
[S01] 可是云端的对象存储在底层默认跨越多个可用区，为你做了数据冗余复制，哪怕一整个数据中心被洪水淹没，数据也不会丢失，这是本地硬盘给不了的底气
[S02] 你在这里，呃，完全混淆了数据冗余和分布式计算架构的概念
[S01] 有什么不同？它们都是云原生的优势
[S02] 大不相同。如果是为了防范主板烧毁，我们可以对单节点数据库做流式的跨机房主从复制，这在技术上非常成熟，并不复杂。但这绝不意味着我们需要把每一次查询的计算和存储都拆得七零八落，通过网络互相调用
[S01] 这是架构的演进
[S02] 但这是有代价的演进。更危险的是，一旦你把存储在物理层面拆散，你的代码结构也会随之支离破碎
[S01] 你的意思是，基础设施的物理分布不可避免地改变了代码的部署范式
[S02] 没错，就是微服务架构的根源。微服务本质上是解决大规模人员组织问题的方案，是为了让几百个开发团队互不打架。但在技术层面，它带来了极其可怕的后果
[S01] 我觉得你这有点夸张了
[S02] 一点也不夸张。每个微服务独占自己的数据库，这意味着你彻底打破了关系型数据库中最珍贵的数据一致性。你想象一下，一个用户购买商品，订单服务更新了状态，但网络突然抖动，导致下游的库存服务没有收到扣减指令
[S01] 这确实是个典型问题
[S02] 对啊，在单体数据库中，这是一个非常简单的事务回滚。但在微服务中，分布式事务是一个极度复杂且容易出错的噩梦
[S01] 确实分布式事务非常棘手，但这正是为什么我们需要引入诸如 SAGA模式，或者通过现代的可观测性工具来进行补偿操作。微服务和无服务器架构，比如 FaaS，将基础设施管理的沉重负担转移给了云厂商
[S02] 也就是说，为了解决一个本不存在的问题，引入了更复杂的解决方案
[S01] 不，这是敏捷性的体现。从前，系统管理员需要半夜爬起来给服务器扩容，现在依靠自动化的DevOps 工具，团队可以独立部署，而且我们要看整体的财务模型，无服务器架构将计费模式从传统的预先购买硬件转变为精确的计量计费，代码运行了多少毫秒，你就付多少钱，这都合理啊
[S02] 单从账单上看是这样，但无服务器架构同样伴随着巨大的妥协，比如冷启动延迟
[S01] 冷启动确实是个现实挑战
[S02] 想象一下，在一个电商闪购秒杀的瞬间，用户点击了去结账。这时候因为流量激增，系统居然需要先去云端分配资源，启动一个微小的容器，加载整个运行环境，然后才能开始处理这条请求
[S01] 现代云厂商把这个时间已经压得很低了
[S02] 但对于用户来说，这就意味着结账页面卡顿了两秒钟。这短短两秒钟的延迟，在真实的商业环境里，可能意味着数百万美元的购物车被放弃。这就是你为了所谓的按毫秒计费付出的业务代价
[S01] 但是
[S02] 还有，更不用提为了监控这个支离破碎的系统，你被迫引入了像 OpenTelemetry这样的工具。为了监控一个分布式系统，你不得不搭建另一个极其复杂的分布式系统，你不觉得这是一种巨大的讽刺吗？
[S01] 我不认为这是讽刺，这是架构演进的必然成本。你提到了电商秒杀的场景，确实，冷启动客观存在，微服务确实有网络开销。但如果你坚持使用传统的单体架构，为了应对那一秒钟的秒杀流量，你只能怎么做？你只能按照最高峰值去配置极其昂贵的服务器集群
[S02] 这是容量规划的一部分
[S01] 但结果就是在剩下百分之九十九的非秒杀时间里，那些昂贵的机器都在空转，自动化治理工具和微服务的存在，正是为了抹平这些痛点，让我们能在全球尺度上享受到极致的弹性红利
[S02] 看来我们似乎在系统设计的复杂性边界上有着根本的分歧。不过我们先退一步，当我们构建了如此庞大、复杂且能够无限制扩展的分布式系统来收集和处理海量数据后，我们必须面对一个更严肃的现实结果
[S01] 你指什么结果？
[S02] 你在开场时提到了以防万一原则，主张尽可能多地保留未经加工的原始数据
[S01] 对，因为在机器学习领域里，你永远不知道明天的算法需要什么样的数据特征。今天看起来无意义的用户点击日志，明天可能就是训练推荐模型的最关键权重，这是大数据的核心逻辑
[S02] 这正是大数据时代的投机哲学，但这直接与现代隐私法规，比如 GDPR的核心精神产生了猛烈冲突
[S01] 合规问题永远存在
[S02] 但法规明确要求的是数据最小化，个人数据只能为指定的明确的目的收集，并且必须在业务完成后的最短时间删除。你不能为了未来未知的机器学习训练，就永远霸占用户的数据
[S01] 呃，但我们当然可以通过脱敏和加密技术来应对合规要求啊
[S02] 没那么简单。让我们看看底层机制，很多现代的高并发数据系统，比如 Kafka这样的消息队列，它是基于不可变日志，也就是 append-only logs设计的
[S01] 是的，这是为了保证高吞吐量
[S02] 这就好比你用不可擦除的墨水，在一个装订好的厚厚日记本上，按时间顺序记录下所有事情。现在，一个用户行使了被遗忘权，要求你彻底删除他在三个月前产生的所有行为数据
[S01] 这在技术实现上讲的确是个难点，因为日志是不可变的
[S02] 何止是难点，简直是工程噩梦啊。因为日志是不可变的，你不能直接跳到那一行，用橡皮擦掉。为了删除这条记录，你要么必须把这本几百 TB 大小的日记本从头到尾重新抄写一遍，在抄写时剔除那个用户的数据
[S01] 这显然不现实
[S02] 呃，对，要么你必须实现极其复杂的加密粉碎技术，也就是为每一条记录单独生成加密密钥，删除时销毁密钥来达到逻辑删除。这不仅消耗极其庞大的计算资源，而且极容易出错。无限期地存储数据，最终让合规操作变成了拖垮系统的最后一根稻草
[S01] 嗯，我非常理解在不可变日志中执行精准删除的工程挑战，但这恰恰证明了我的观点
[S02] 哦，怎么说？
[S01] 在如今这个数据无处不在的时代，你无法靠退回到单节点的极简时代来解决合规问题。如果企业里有几十个部门都在使用数据，数据早就散落在各个角落了。合规的复杂性恰恰正是我们需要云级别的专业分布式治理工具的原因
[S02] 但如果你从一开始就不去收集这些非必要数据呢？问题从源头上就不存在了
[S01] 但商业的运转需要数据驱动。为了在满足合规的同时继续发挥数据价值，我们需要在数据湖之上建立强大的元数据层，以及极其严密的 IAM，也就是身份与访问管理控制。通过复杂的权限隔离和数据血缘追踪，我们可以精确知道某个用户的数据流向了哪些模型，这不是简单的单机数据库能做到的
[S02] 可是，再严密的 IAM控制，也无法消除数据本身存在的物理风险。文献中提到过，在某些情况下，庞大的数据集合可能会暴露弱势群体的行踪，给用户带来真正的人身安全风险
[S01] 绝对的，安全性永远是首位的
[S02] 当系统受到黑客攻击或发生内部泄露时，你投机性存储的每一条额外数据都会转化成毁灭性的声誉损失和天价的法律罚款。在这种情况下，数据最小化，也就是从系统设计的第一天起，就克制住收集一切的欲望，不去投机性地存储，才是最负责任也最安全的架构决策。极简不仅是性能上的优越，更是风险管理上的智慧
[S01] 看来我们触及到了系统设计的深层哲学，这是一场非常精彩且深入的交锋。我想在此总结一下我的立场
[S02] 请讲
[S01] 现代数据密集型系统的复杂性，绝不是工程师们为了炫技而创造出来的。它是业务需求演进到全球尺度下的必然结果。无论是事务与分析在逻辑层面的分离，还是云原生架构下计算与存储在物理层面的彻底解耦，亦或是微服务映射出的敏捷组织架构，这些设计赋予了我们前所未有的弹性、容错能力和分析深度。它们让应用能够在面临不可预测的突发流量、底层硬件故障，甚至是严苛的全球合规要求时，依然能够依靠强大的自动化治理工具持续稳健地运行
[S02] 而我的总结是，我们必须对盲目追求分布式与云化复杂性的狂热趋势保持极度警惕。复杂性本身就是系统最大的敌人。在许多真实的商业场景下，现代单节点架构配合其极高的性能利用率和微秒级的本地磁盘延迟，在性能上远超那些被网络开销拖垮的庞大集群。如果我们能奉行严格的数据最小化原则，只收集业务真正需要的数据，我们不仅能大幅降低系统架构的复杂性，避免坠入分布式事务和微服务冷启动的运维地狱，更能彻底消减法律合规和数据泄露带来的巨大隐藏成本。极简往往意味着更高的确定性和更强的掌控力
[S01] 我想我们可以在一点上找到共识。正如文献中所展现的，没有完美的解决方案，只有权衡取舍
[S02] 确实如此
[S01] 到底是选择依靠一台性能强悍、极简克制的单节点系统，还是去打造一个高度解耦、无限扩展的云原生分布式架构，其实高度依赖于特定的负载波动特征，团队的工程能力，以及这个组织所愿意承受的风险与道德责任
[S02] 完全同意。理解这些对比视角的根本目的，不是为了在学术上证明某一种技术路径永远正确，而是为了让我们在搭建数据基础建设的第一天能够提出正确的问题。我们要看到分布式系统带来无限扩展的可能性，同时也要学会欣赏极简架构与数据克制所蕴含的强大力量
[S01] 在这份源自《设计数据密集型应用》第二版第一章的探讨中，还有更多关于数据系统底层机制的精妙设计，值得我们去钻研。了解复杂系统背后的物理定律与逻辑限制，是每一位技术决策者的必修课。本次探讨到此结束，将最终的判断交由听众自己思考。欢迎下次继续收听